was the lizard a waste of cgi does
electro's makeover make the cut we put
spider-man's villains at a head-to-head
showdown to answer one question who's
the best at being bad
in spider-man no way home willem dafoe
alfred molina thomas hayden church reese
e fans and jamie foxx are all back in
their respective roles as the green
goblin doctor octopus the sandman the
lizard and electro it's time to line up
this quintet of antagonists and rank the
maddest baddest villains in spider-man
no way home
scale obsessed scientist dr kirk connors
was the first foe of andrew garfield
spider-man back in 2012's the amazing
spider-man the lizard returns in
spider-man no way home but has the least
screen time of all the villains not even
warranting a worthy entrance his arrival
happens off-screen after he's captured
by doctor strange while peter is dealing
with electro and sandman from there he's
left in the van for a lengthy portion of
the film before being a forgetful cgi
beastie chasing after the webslinger
even the method of putting him out of
action is identical to his demise in the
amazing spider-man sadly the lizard
feels like a plus one only there to
build out the numbers
the triple threat that rounds off the
original group of cinematic spider-man
villains comes in the form of flint
marco also known as the sandman last
seen making amends for pasdees and toby
maguire's spider-man 3 marco is still a
danger to this particular wall crawler
although not nearly as much as the rest
in the lineup while prominent for most
of the film his presence does raise a
few questions in the final act that sees
him fighting against our heroes for
reasons that aren't too clear instead
he's only put to the forefront when it's
time for him to burst into action while
still a feast for the eyes the sandman
makes for an ill-fitting piece to the
much grander puzzle of no way home
if all the foes are face off against
spider-man and no way home electro is
without a doubt the one that's had the
most drastic change since the last time
we saw him in the amazing spider-man 2.
jamie foxx's original iteration was a
bumbling scientist with a comb over but
the maxwell dylan we're reunited with
here is quite simply much more like the
actor that plays him somehow dylan's
time in the grid after his failed effort
to become pure energy has turned him
into one of the few criminals and this
group you might want to hang out with
that being said his obsession with a new
form of energy does make him a force to
be reckoned with making him an excellent
fit for third place
spider-man's enigmatic enemy and
director sam raimi's original trilogy dr
otto octavius is just as charming and
equally chilling upon his return in
spider-man no way home wait no seriously
what's your actual name
and unsurprisingly alfred molina's
portrayal of the scientists we've not
seen him play for 17 years is seamless
from his scattered memories of a
fistfight with spider-man to battling
with the voices in his head molina makes
it crystal clear why his performance in
spider-man 2 made him one of the best
comic book movie villains in history we
know that octavius resorted to violence
and criminal means to achieve his goal
but we still manage to see the flicker
of a good man in his final moments in no
way home more time is spent ensuring
that the seemingly lost cause is found
and sticks around a little longer
darkhog feels almost scrooge-like here
before learning the error of his ways
making his turn back to the light a joy
to see
no one gives their character more
attention or advancement than willem
dafoe as norman osborne also known as
the green goblin the first foe of toby
maguire's spider-man could have easily
phoned in his performance instead he
gets back into both mindsets as a man
and the monster controlling him making
him one of the most formidable enemies
holland spidey has faced in spider-man
no way home taking the iconic but
performance limiting mask out of the
equation makes a split between osborne
and green goblin so much more potent and
petrifying holland's hero is pushed to
his limits by a monster on a glider that
effortlessly gets inside his head
there's no denying that the mcu has
hosted many great villains over the
years but green goblin reminds us that
he helped set the bar long before the
universe even existed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]